alex jones is saving lives
oh god i saw this this is a great video
alex jones is saving lives let's see
here come the kids uh with the migrants
from all
over central america uh honduras
guatemala
you name it right and we're just gonna
go ahead and film them and not blur the
kids faces at all because you know
once they go into this facility the
border patrol completely washes their
hands with them
if they test negative they're marched
right down the street to the catholic
charity
from there they're giving clothes food
financial assistance
the debit cards that they have have over
twelve hundred dollars per person on
them
they're then taken to the mcallen
airport and unmarked vans
and then they're released into the
united states to a destination
city of their choice
and here's where it gets fun this is
great so this guy
is uh putting children the staff member
is putting children in a the back of a
looks like an suv
for
now regardless of where this video is
going he is correct you can't just
[ __ ]
pile a bunch of kids into the boot of an
suv
i hear what you're saying but i would
like to uh
counter that they are mexican oh
of course that was my favorite part of
this video is alex is like what are you
doing with all these kids crammed into a
car and i'm like alex this is not the
first
time in austin texas you've seen 75
mexican children crammed into a car
was the first time it wasn't a [ __ ]
toyota vehicle that's true
traffic accidents where are you taking
these kids do you have a car
actually there
you're violating texas law who who is
this right here
right you got no comments you've got to
post children
you're about to run a human being over
here he's alex is pushing the car like
some sort of super bowl that's what he's
getting he can move the car easily with
his mind
in there you got those struggle children
illegally who are you
where are you taking these smuggling
children are you you got to be legally
in that vehicle
you're not a part of this me you're
going
to a mcdonald's detective to get a job
a taking a piece of it
who are you
oh it is a toyota my apologies
this is a massive smuggling this is
literally human
smuggling these are children where are
you taking these kids
and now sir they've got people from kids
they don't even have car seats
your seat belts aren't even on where are
you taking these children
sir identify yourself who are you
[ __ ] hit me i'll tell you right [ __ ]
who do you work for
mr liberty alex jones is all of a sudden
now he's a seat belt [ __ ]
are you a part of this organization not
sure i don't know
so you don't know where these kids are
going they're going to
no no they they came from over there
they're not being checked for covet
so you don't where are they sending
these kids what's happening here
uh i really i'm serious joking aside
where are they sending these children
no clue i don't know who you are call
the police
we need to call the police right now i
want to know where these kids are going
you are violating state law
they're not going there you're not
making any sense here identify yourself
who are you
out of that back man if somebody rear
ends you those kids are going to get
hurt
who are these kids
well i'm sorry when they're children in
your car and someone asks you who are
these kids your answer shouldn't be
i don't know i mean at least he's honest
i don't know i don't know they pay me
ten dollars a day to drive him around
because where did you get them from from
the church from the church where's the
church
from one okay so we just want to make
sure that this is all good okay sir
i understand you're probably trying to
help at least appearing too
but you literally have a bunch of kids
in here a bunch of miners all by
yourself
okay no seat belt no anything
[Music]
your human smuggler's gonna stop free so
you're you're cool with human smuggling
yes i don't care about you he's getting
a phone call right now
uh yeah uh jose it's uh
tony podesta again are you is the
package secure
or what are we doing here there's a lot
of people waiting for hot dogs at this
party i am
very annoyed needless to say i may not
be using catholic charities again
for all my child needs i have a rabbi on
the other line he's willing to step in
you know the catholics have done a great
job over hundreds of years of really
building a stunning reputation and right
now you're ruining it
you're ruining it
i go to hollywood fashion too for all my
fashion dates
where do you go shopping for all your
clothes ah hollywood fashion oh is that
in hollywood
it's uh austin it's austin texas but
it's uh you know
they're being raped in traffic
guys guys guys guys guys i know you need
your little
i know you need your little photo op and
everything but the cops are here now
the cops are there now yes you know what
i mean like it's it's i was with them up
to this point but now it's like okay
boys
boys boys he's getting his id he's
handling it
i wonder what's going to happen calm
down let's like that now
it you you start to really become very
obviously concerned
more with the making a scene part it's
like they're there
well i think it's because the other
people are saying something [ __ ] with
them i that's at least when i see i mean
i don't know
do you know how do i know it's happening
these people do not care at all
don't ask her for an id because i don't
think you're going to get one
here
buddy shut up i want to hear what the
cops are saying dude being a cop on the
border has to be
just it's the worst yeah
can i say forget all the scene and all
that happening but
whenever people are saying that they're
sending moms across with troves of
children
first i mean if those are all her
children which they probably are i'm
gonna honestly
guess they probably are if you're so
destitute in this country
if you in mexico if you're so destitute
in mexico and you can't afford to feed
your kids and you can't afford to do
anything
why are you having so many children
there's like six thousand dollars worth
of stimulus checks in that car right now
i'll be honest with you
that's what it's loaded with quite a few
a couple of bucks
what organization is this i want to know
who the hell this is stuffing kids in
the back of a car without any
it's way fair no oh it's a way for
delivery man that's all
i'm just delivering oh man
what kind of catholic organization is
this i mean a normal one
it's doing what it should do right
that's what they do if we're being on
we're being fair here right for catholic
charity
for catholics this is pretty on brand
right
maybe a chariot should be ashamed of
yourself
a donkey of some sort of movie of camel
esp
every single one of you
um that's the video i like that he's
like you guys are evil and there's like
a bunch of catholic charities people in
there going uh yeah duh
hello we're catholic yeah i
our pope washes the feet of people now
hello uh we know sweetie